tick tock it's the hugely popular app
that's given rise to dance trends
viral recipes influencer mansions
and national security investigations
we're looking at tick tock we may be
banning tick tock
tick tock has caught on so fast it's
come to rival some of the world's
biggest social media companies
in just a few years three words
addictive fun
addictive i think tick tock is
unique in how quickly it's grown before
tick tock was a global sensation
it was a chinese app called dogeen
here's how tiktok
became tiktok and racked up billions of
downloads so quickly
in 2012 a tech startup called bite dance
was founded by a chinese entrepreneur in
his late 20s
who admired silicon valley icons and had
done a brief stint at microsoft
by dance has actually been around for
eight years now
in the company's origin story you know
they talk about
starting out of like a modest apartment
in beijing
and johnny ming so the founder and ceo
of bite dance
he was in part motivated to start by
dance because
he noticed how a lot of people in china
were now reading the news off their
phone
after creating an ai driven news
platform that still exists today
bite dance launched a short video
sharing app in 2016
called dojin users could upload videos
put popular songs in the background and
work with an array of editing tools all
within the app
going in china was also kind of marketed
as a way let's say for companies or
brands
to get in touch with gen z but
since it only operates in china it's
subject to chinese regulations
which means certain topics can be
censored
if bite dance wanted to go global with
the app it had to make some tweaks for
international markets
so in 2017 tick tock was born
dojin stayed in chinese app stores and
tiktok was made available in apple and
google play stores abroad
in its first year on the global market
bite dance acquired musically
a lip-syncing app popular in north
america and folded it into tick-tock
i thought this was an app for teens i
thought
no way am i going to like this thing i
just figured okay
they're dancing on there they're telling
funny jokes they're doing pranks
this is what tic toc is all about joanna
stern
the journal's personal tech columnist
says she was hooked
[Music]
and many users seem to agree just a year
after its launch
tick tock was one of the top 10 apps
downloaded globally
i became pretty obsessed with watching
these memes where people would use
iggy azalea's walk a mile in these louis
vuitton song
[Music]
by 2019 tick tock was available in 150
countries and 75 languages
rivaling some of the world's biggest
apps like facebook
instagram and whatsapp and as many users
started using it as a platform to
release more politically charged videos
on issues including brexit and the us
election tiktok
has been accused of taking down content
that's sensitive in china
including pro-democracy protests in hong
kong
tick tock repeatedly pushed back saying
that it operates independently
and that political content is allowed as
long as it's light-hearted and creative
i think the big thing that happened in
2020 is that you had tick tock becoming
far more appealing to older users the
teens sort of had
set the pace on tick tock they created a
ton of content and then
you had these older generations coming
on and
sharing more about their professions
about the world about
politics and i think that was a pretty
big turning point
from this social network going from fun
dancing yay
rainbows to a real world social network
in april tiktok hit 2 billion global
downloads
but that level of global attention also
brought questions into whether the
chinese-owned app
poses national security risks shouldn't
we be considering
right now tonight a ban on chinese
social media apps especially
tick tock lord your viewers should know
we're taking this very seriously
we're certainly looking at it after the
trump administration labeled tiktok as a
national security threat
and accused it of potentially sharing
data with the chinese government
the company responded that it wouldn't
share user information with the chinese
authorities even if they asked
other governments including the european
union and australia
have launched investigations into tiktok
as well india
tick tock's largest foreign market went
so far as to ban the app in june
and it's not just politicians watching
tick tocks every move
social media companies are trying to
replicate the app's success with young
people
i think tik tok is unique because it
doesn't require a social network
to push you content and i think that
makes it very different from
twitter and facebook right which is all
about your connections but i think tick
tock
totally is kind of divorced from that
right like you don't really need to
follow anybody for you to use the app or
for it to start learning from your
browsing behavior part of what makes
tick tock so popular
and addictive is its hyper personalized
feed
called the for you page the algorithm
analyzes how long users watch each video
and instantly serves up a new one based
on their viewing patterns
and a lot of the content is relatable
across country borders
so if you're scrolling tik tok from the
us you might see videos from people
everywhere from
france to indonesia or the uk not just
people nearby
we're now seeing lots of social media
platforms trying to clone tick tock but
what we're seeing is they can't actually
do that without the algorithm without
the content that then fuels people to
keep watching
instagram has introduced a new reels
feature that many users say is similar
to tick tock's interface
but still doesn't feel nearly as
addictive as scrolling through tik-tok
instagram said it's constantly looking
for ways to improve user experience
with the threat of a ban on tick-tock
many tick-tockers
seem less concerned about personal data
and more about keeping tick tock
what it is the secret sauce really
seemed to be the combination of music
short videos and easy editing tools and
then
this algorithmic feed the for you feed
which dropped you into this immersive
experience
and didn't give you a lot of choice i
don't think it's easily easy enough to
just say we're gonna clone that
and so i think that might be something
that we all end up missing
in mid-september as it hoped to avoid a
ban of tick-tock in the u.s
bite dance submitted a proposal to the
trump administration to work with oracle
an american company to address national
security concerns
the deal has to be approved by the trump
administration